louis van gaal était super content les
avis des clients ravis pouvoir acheter à
nouveau des livres est un soulagement
une manière d'échapper au confinement
bien content de pouvoir trouver des
livres quand même on commence un peu à
s'ennuyer
la réouverture est partiel les commandes
se font sur internet et les clients les
récupérant drive pour cette libraire
refaire fonctionner son commerce était
devenu financièrement indispensable
économiquement je pense que tout le
monde comprend à quel point un commerce
indépendant fragile en plus comme comme
l'est la librairie c'est quelque chose
de dean envisageable de fermer quatre
semaines à quelques kilomètres de là les
clients tous des habitués sont reçus
uniquement sur rendez vous le paiement
se fait par carte bancaire
les gestes barrières sont respectées
pour cette grande et fidèle lectrice
c'est une façon de soutenir le commerce
de proximité
j'ai un très bon et des noms mais je
viens toujours là pas de raison que
jaïro commande sur amazon pour cette
libraire c'est réouverture c'est tout un
symbole la colère à un moment elle a été
là elle a été vive de se dire ok
pourquoi nous libraire on doit fermer
alors que finalement on vous dit que le
livre n'est pas une denrée essentielle
vous n'avez pas besoin d'acheter des
livres pendant cette période difficile
et vous trouver quand même du livre à
vendre ailleurs
tous nous l'ont confié il espère un
retour à la normale le plus rapidement
possible